[Musique]
petit j'étais fasciné par ce type
d'image c'est une image que je
retrouvais dans mes okapi qui sont des
livres d'enfants dans lequel on retrouve
un peu d'histoire un peu de philosophie
enfin plein de choses et puis c'est une
image que je retrouvais aussi dans mes
cahiers de catéchisme j'étais
complètement fasciné par cette image
parce qu'elles représentent des enfants
de différentes nationalités de
différentes couleurs de peau qui se
tiennent par la main et qu'il faut une
sorte de chaîne humaine autour de la
terre une image fabuleuse je me pose est
quand même la question de savoir comment
c'était possible parce que certains
devaient dormir pendant que d'autres
devaient aller à l'école et d'autres
encore ne vais vaquer à ses occupations
mais avait quand même une multiplication
de décalage horaire que je m'expliquais
pas mais en fait j'y croyais je vivais
avec cette es16 d'utopie de l'enfance
qui fait que quand on est enfant on a le
coeur bon on pense que le monde est
merveilleux que tout le monde est bon
l'utopie est au creux de tout enfant
utopie suis l'enfant jusqu'à son âge
adulte l'enfant
il a peur de plein de choses il a peur
des zombies la peur des mauvaises notes
il a peur du noir il a peur des
revenants quand il tombe il se relève
tout de suite après il éclate de rire la
seconde suivante et puis on recommence
il tombe il se relève la joie est encore
plus forte la goût de vivre pour vivre
l'enfant joue avec la peur
il a contourné la détourne la frôle même
la peur est une composante importante
dans l'enfant est bien cette utopie qui
m'a suivi pendant mon enfance
un jour elle m'a quitté elle m'a pas
quittée longtemps elle m'a quittée parce
que simplement j'avais grandi et je
m'étais rendu compte que finalement le
monde n'était pas si facile que les
rapports humains étaient difficiles et
puis j'avais un regard très lucide sur
le monde
elle est revenue grâce à ma pratique
artistique et j'ai placé l'utopie au
sein de mon propos artistique
l'utopie comme arme dans mon art et
l'art comme arme pour défendre un propos
et pour défendre mes idées là c'est
quelque chose de magnifique parce que la
retouche au coeur la retouche au sens
large touche à l'émotion
l'artiste c'est aussi quelqu'un de
magnifique parce que simplement on peut
tout faire à partir de rien on peut
créer n'importe quel beau projet
artistique on peut faire passer nos
idées à travers n'importe quel médium
que ce soit une oeuvre peinte une
sculpture on arrive à toucher les gens
au coeur et l'art questionne sur tout
alors avec ma pratique artistique
je questionne je questionne le monde
avec lucidité je regarde le monde et je
lutte
je suis une artiste activistes qui rêve
le monde
je suis une artiste utopiste alors
comment je vais me prendre pour lutter
et contre quoi je vais lutter je vais
lutter au regard de mon identité créole
et au regard de tout ce que je vois dans
le monde je vais lutter contre tout acte
de domination et de discrimination qui
sont pour moi
deux facteurs importants qui régissent
le monde plus fortement le monde
contemporain aujourd'hui et qui vise et
qui servent à reproduire les réflexes de
domination des classes sociales
dominantes
je vais incorporé au sein de ma
problématique
l'artiste et rêveur mais pas tant que ça
parfois je vais inséré au sein de ma
problématique cette espèce de violence
symbolique dont parle pierre bourdieu
fameux philosophe français qui consiste
à forcer tout un peuple
toute une communauté
à accepter tout acte de violences et de
domination comme étant des actes naturel
et légitime
je rappelle que ce principe de violence
symbolique est à la base de toute sorte
de domination est à la base de l
esclavage alors j'ai plusieurs façons de
lutter avec différents types de projets
une façon de lutter ce sont des
installations que je vais poser dans les
musées comme cette installation de robes
qui sont un mélange de robes de
différentes classes sociales les classes
de la bourgeoisie et des classes et des
robes d'esclaves mais qui sont présentés
de façon uniforme
réalisé avec un papier qu'on appelle le
papier d'yvette qui est un papier très
fragile mais en fait rigide à la fois
qui est pour moi la métaphore de
l'humanité l'espèce de fragilité de
l'humanité et puis ces robes sont
représentés de même blanc immaculé y
éclairé exactement de la même manière qu
est ce que je dis par là je rêve de
l'égalité sociale je rêve d'une espèce
de nivee lation social mon utopie qui
parle
et puis d'autres projets plus importants
et qui sont vraiment au coeur de ma
problématique actuelle un projet qui
s'appelle acta non verba à terre-neuve
herbacée du latin je vais me mettre en
avant
je vais me mettre sur scène et je vais
endosser la robe coloniale au regard de
mon identité encore une fois je vais
endosser la posture des classes
dirigeantes et je vais dénoncer avec de
simples gestes je vais dire regarder le
monde tel qu'il est écouter les bruits
du monde
et puis arrêtez de blabla parler ça sert
à rien de parler il faut agir plutôt que
par les actes à non verba veut dire agir
plutôt que parler à ta non verba acta
non verba acta non verba ata non verbe
en fait ce projet je les placer dans
plusieurs dans plusieurs lieux
significatifs comme par exemple le train
américain pottu swan qui est un lieu de
pouvoir mais je les place est ici comme
aussi dans une laverie automatique
lavaud automatique aux états unis ce
sont des lieux où les gens passent des
journées à laver leur linge du quotidien
leur linge de tous les jours et c'était
une espèce de fourmilière et donc je
m'impose sans trompette dans des lieux
n'importe quel type de lieu et je
performe
cette performance est accompagné d'un
très beau chant d'amour de gabriel fauré
qui s'intitule après un rêve
[Musique]
oh non
bon
on
[Musique]
oh
aussi
alors qu'est ce que je dis dans cette
performance je dis simplement si on acte
pas si on ne fait pas aujourd'hui on n'a
pas ce sont de gabriel fauré ce rêve je
dis tout le temps
nous sommes là le rêve il est là il faut
aller le chercher le rêve alors cette
performance elle a eu un impact
pratiquement partout où elle est passée
elle est aujourd'hui soutenu par line
height foundation qui une importante
fondation aux états unis qui soutient
les projets qui ont un impact sur la
société
elle est soutenue aujourd'hui par
l'organisation des nations-unies
une autre partie de mon travail
le pendant du travail tout comme le le
l'après rêve de gabriel fauré ce sont
des grandes peintures ou des tapisseries
que je présente dans les lieux mise
muséaux et qui représente l'envers du
décor le rêve
comment on peut représenter le monde
avec toute sa beauté toute sa
magnificence
le noir est très important dans mes
peintures j'utilise le noir le noir
c'est le noir c'est quoi le noir héros
représentent les ténèbres le deuil dans
nos dans notre société judéo-chrétienne
l'austérité le mal le diable et même
pour moi non je place le noir comme acte
de résistance
le noir c'est un acte de résistance pour
moi vous savez ce qu'est le noir le noir
de façon scientifique et chimiques
le noir est composé de toutes les
couleurs de l'univers ce qui veut dire
que dans la couleur noire vous avez
toute la beauté du monde et toute la
beauté de l'univers de façon
métaphorique et encore avec mon utopie
imaginez la force d'une personne de
couleur noire
imaginez la force du peuple noir c'est
une métaphore
ce que je veux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est c'est que du vivons dans un monde
merveilleux 10 world is amazing jamais
siècle d'apporter autant de lutte pour
l'égalité pour la paix jamais siècle
d'apporter autant de d'espoir alors si
vous ne trouvez pas au fond de votre
garde-robe la robe coloniale pour les
hommes ça va être la redingote
mais si vous n'avez pas trouvé ça au
fond de votre garde-robe stade que vous
allez vous aurez trouvé autre chose et
si encore vous n'avez rien trouvé mais
vraiment rien alors il faudra que vous
alliez chercher ce petit enfant qui est
tapi au fond de vous qui lisait les
okapis et lui demander alors toi tu vois
le monde comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]